BRUCE: On behalf of the Reading
Odyssey and Collaborative
Gain and Google, to this
special presentation
of "Julius Caesar," one of the
greatest works of all time.
It's kind of fitting that we're
presenting this book at Google
within the entire
tech community, which
puts such a big emphasis
on product experience
and user experience and design.
These books-- I
met Bob Strassler,
the series editor,
10 years ago when
I was a reporter at "Forbes."
Now I'm in PR, if
you will, because it
was an amazing story of an
entrepreneur, if you will,
or someone who had retired
and saw a need in the market
for essentially, a
usable classics series.
Because the books that everyone
was using for almost 100 years,
those Penguin
editions are dense.
There's maybe one
map in the beginning
with dozens of labels on it.
No footnotes.
No context.
And you're just thrown into it
as a student in high school.
And obviously, it turns
off a lot of people,
and they never get
back to the classics
again, which is a huge loss.
So Bob said, wait.
I can fix that.
So he took his own
money and decided
to design an edition
that had all of that.
Every page would be
dripping with context.
There'd be a place, a time,
footnotes, side notes,
pictures, maps in context.
He did it all by hand, hired a
few people out of the academia
after getting a
lot of rejections
from university professors
saying, you can't do this.
You're an amateur.
Well, that's usually
the best kinds
of people, the
passionate amateur.
So this series came out.
The first edition came
out almost 20 years ago,
"Landmark Thucydides."
I caught up with
Bob 10 years ago,
and he was just putting
out a second one, "Landmark
Herodotus."
And since then, there's
been at least two more.
This is the fifth, I think.
And it's one of the bestselling
classics series of all time.
So without further ado, I
won't give any much more away,
because Bob will tell you the
story of how it all began.
And we'll hear a
lot from the editor
of this particular volume,
Kurt, who's here as well.
A professor from Brown, who's
one of the world's experts
on Caesar, to tell you
the story behind the book.
[APPLAUSE]
ROBERT STRASSLER:
Thank you, Bruce.
It's a pleasure
to be here today.
I am proposing to spend
a little further time
on what Landmark books are.
And to explain why and
how they were determined
to be the way they are.
And how we hope to accomplish
certain things with them.
And then after that, we'll
talk about the challenges
to Landmark books
that were posed
by the immense amount
of data that is known
about Caesar and his world.
We were delighted
with the amount.
And then we were
drowned in the amount
and we had to flounder
with it a while.
We came up, we hope,
with an optimum solution.
And then if I have
time, I'm going
to talk about
Caesar as a general.
Illustrate some of his skills,
looking at three battles
that he undertook.
In each, his role
is quite different.
They're quite different battles.
And the third one, he
didn't write this narrative.
It was written by an unknown
author who was clearly
an eyewitness and
very likely is thought
to be an officer in his
army at that third battle.
I hope we get to
all of them, but I'm
determined to give Kurt
Raaflaub, my colleague
here, all of his time that
he certainly well deserves.
So let's talk about
the Landmark books.
It occurred to me
about 30 years ago,
when I was doing a little
teaching at a place called
Simon's Rock of Bard College.
I discovered that my
students had difficulty
dealing with the histories.
They handled Homer.
They handled the poetry.
They handled the
plays, which were often
very foreign in content.
And they'd come to
Herodotus and Thucydides
and you'd think, well,
that's duck soup.
It reads like a history,
which it does because they
set the paradigm of histories.
We write the way
they wrote history.
And I would watch with
dismay as one by one,
the eyes of the students
would glaze over.
And you'd see that
they were lost,
and they couldn't
keep up with it,
and didn't know from where this
happened and why that happened.
And I decided that it was a
problem of the two editions
that we had for students,
Modern Library and Penguin.
Those are both very
good translations.
But in the volume, they
are simply black pages.
As Bruce said, there are
no appendices worth a damn.
The maps are in the back,
a little section where
pretty soon you stop going
because the names on the maps
are not spelled the same way
as the names in the text.
And so you're never sure
if this is the right place.
And what's more, some
of them are modern maps
and the places have moved.
And in a lot of ways, they're
just less help than harm.
And most students,
I think, just stop
using them because they're
difficult to get to
and they provide little in the
way of additional information.
And in addition,
there are things
that go on in the ancient world
which puzzled modern readers.
Why not?
What can they be expected to
know about a religion that
has animal sacrifice?
It sounds sort of primitive,
and brutal, and nasty.
And certainly, foreign.
Or the problems, let's say, of
a very complex political system
like Rome's political system in
the last years of the Republic.
Or the problems of running
a boat with the engine being
175 people rowing it who
need to be fed and slept
and all kinds of
things every night.
So these are difficulties that
even the most astute and I
would say well-educated, but not
classics-educated modern reader
is going to need help to
figure out what's going on.
So those gaps in knowledge,
those gaps in culture,
have to be somehow filled.
And we determined to fill
them in the Landmark books.
We have explanatory footnotes.
Let me show you this guy here.
We'll get to him in a minute.
We have explanatory footnotes.
For real questions like, what
is religion in the pagan world,
we have an appendix
in the back--
In this case, not in the
back, but on the web--
that the reader can go to get
as much information as he wants.
We have maps that
are clear and that
are embedded in the
text within a page
or two of the relevant sections
that they are supporting.
So there's no going to the back.
We have illustrations
also embedded.
Not to be pretty, as you'll see.
I'll show you a few of them.
Although, some of
them are pretty.
But they're not adornments.
They're there to emphasize
the historicity of the text.
This is not a
Tolkien fairy tale.
There were no dragons and
there were no flying elephants.
These events really happened
to people who fought and died
and didn't know in the morning
what was going to happen,
just as you don't know
in the morning what's
going to happen particularly.
And they suffered, and
planned, and did all the things
that you do in their way.
And it is a true story.
It is real.
It's important to
impress students
with that because it's
all too easy to begin
to think with these foreign
names and foreign places
and strange goings on,
I'll just get a good exam.
I don't have to worry
about it too much.
That's a mistake.
If you lose the
sense of historicity,
you've lost half of the
value of these books.
That's my personal opinion.
In any case, we give all
kinds of other supports.
We have, as I mentioned,
the appendices.
We have a glossary.
We have a very rich index.
And we have a
strong introduction
to tell you about the writer.
Of course, in
Caesar's case, it only
can partially tell
you about the writer
because there's so
much you can't put it
into an introductory
section of a book.
But we put as much
into it as we can.
Whenever we think
there's something here
that will cause somebody's
brow to wrinkle up,
what does that mean,
we try to fix it
with a footnote
that explains it.
A footnote that tells
them where to go.
Let me show you a page.
You see, it's the text.
There are side notes for each
chapter, which explain where it
took place, when it took place.
You'd be amazed at how Penguin
and Modern Library don't have
dates for a history of a war.
And then, a little write-up
of where it is because people
need to come back to this book
and figure out where they were.
Because if you've
partied all weekend,
as students do, or even just had
to put it down for two weeks,
as people do, you
come back and you
want to be able to find
out where you were before.
These things help you.
These footnotes are-- you
can't read them, unfortunately.
Down here, you can see
there's a reference
to letters to his brother
Quintus by Cicero.
Quintus was in Caesar's army.
And we learn about
some of the things that
were going on in Caesar's
army from the things
that Quintus
wrote-- his brother.
And particularly, we learn a
few dates because they're dated.
Quintus wrote on
the 17th of June.
And so that helps us
to establish dates.
Up here is one of those--
a reference to Cantium,
which is modern Kent.
Map 519.
Map 519 is right
around the corner.
And here is a coin from
Cantium minted by a king--
a king named Tasciovanus.
But we don't know anything
about him except his coins.
But it's there, again, to
emphasize that this is real.
He mentions this place.
And there's some practical
evidence that it exists.
Now, I talked about maps.
I could show you
some other maps that
are horrible in the Penguin
and the Modern Library.
These you can't
really see very well,
but the purpose is we
have a locator map, which
shows Italy, Britain, and Gaul.
And in the outline is
where this is taking place.
So you're always oriented.
You know where it is.
In effect, this
is a campaign map.
Caesar is dividing about
14 campaigns, more or less.
And in the beginning of each
one, we have a campaign map.
And this one, in fact, is
his first campaign in 48 BC.
He comes running up, A--
and you can follow the
alphabetic letters--
from Cisalpine Gaul, where he
has his winter headquarters.
B, he massacres
the [? Titarini ?]
crossing the river Aras.
And it tells you where in
the text you can find this.
It says here, this is 4--
I don't know-- 26.
Hard to read.
It means it's in chapter
4, Section 26, Bibracte.
He defeats the Helvetii.
Here, he catches up with them
and forces their surrender.
And now he goes after
Ariovistus, the German.
And Ariovistus is here.
Caesar marches on him--
I'm encapsulating a
lot-- wins a victory,
defeats him, and takes
his army from F to G
back to Vizantio for
winter headquarters.
That's what you're going
to read in the book.
And then you go ahead.
There are maps within the
text of the book supporting
what happens in an expanded
way, so that there's
more data, more detail.
But you can always
refer back to this
to find out what was going
to happen next, or whatever.
It's useful to understand.
This is an easy one I picked.
Some of them get pretty
complicated because he
tended to run all over,
go back and over his path.
And in order not
to make them look
like spaghetti running
back and forth,
we had to do some
particular tricks.
In one case in book 7 where
there's a great revolt
and he spends a lot of
time running all over Gaul,
we had two campaign maps
because there was no other way
to show it.
Here's another map that
we'll explain a little bit.
It's very hard for you
to see, but here's Rome.
Here's the coast of
Italy on this map.
Here's the upper Adriatic and
the Adriatic on the other side.
Caesar comes down from Rome
and goes to Brundisium,
chases Pompey out.
And then later, he comes
back to Brundisium,
and he crosses over the
Adriatic to Palaesta.
Now, the telescoping here is
to accomplish different scales
so that you can show detail.
If we put all these places
at this scale over here
on the Adriatic,
it would just be
a bunch of dots all together.
And you'd have trouble
putting the labels on.
You'd have trouble reading them.
You would not, in
effect, have been
imparted any real information.
So in order to
make that clear, we
had another-- a
third telescope map.
This is the square
that shows it.
And here it is.
And at least you now
know that Bouthroton
is at approximately 80
miles from Apollonia.
And you could never
meaningfully show that.
So that's the kind
of thing we do
to try to make the maps
as clear as possible.
There's no extraneous
stuff on these maps.
It's only the labels that
are shown in the text, that
are described in the text.
We try to keep it as
simple as possible.
This is a map I really love,
and we'll come back to it.
It's a campaign in
a way of its own.
Caesar-- you won't
believe this, but he
suffered some serious defeats.
In the vicinity of Dyrrachium,
Pompey beat him badly.
And he caused heavy
casualties into his army.
And Caesar then withdrew
south, skillfully
withdrew from Pompey.
Pompey chased him, but
couldn't catch up with him.
And then Pompey turned
back and went down
the main road, the Via
Egnatia, on his way
to meet Scipio, who
was Pompeian, up
and to head for Pharsalus.
Caesar went south and
had some adventures
here with two cities,
Gomphi and Metropolis,
and ended at Pharsalus.
So it ends up with
the two of them
facing each other at Pharsalus.
Caesar offering battle
and Pompey refusing it.
One little side thing
I should mention.
There was a general,
a Caesarean general,
with two veteran
legions which would
have been very important
to Caesar, who didn't know
anything about that defeat.
Caesar's attempts to
reach him with a courier
didn't get through.
And he's marching
up the Via Egnatia
when his scouts inform him--
and it's an interesting
way they do.
But they're Gauls, and they
run into their brother Gauls,
who are scouting for Pompey.
And they find out he's four
hours' march away from Pompey
coming down the Via
Egnatia with nine legions.
He has two.
So that showed how abruptly
he gets out of there.
And he goes south and
meets Caesar at Aegenium
and on into Pharsalus.
So I think it's
an engagement map.
And all of these
notes down here,
some of which you can
see, explain what's going
on in the A, B, C, Ds and E's.
But-- oh, here's a
picture of what the Via
Egnatia looks like today.
A section of it.
So Pompey might have been there.
Domitius might have been there.
Well, Pompey
certainly was there.
He went the whole way.
So this is a way of explaining
a very complex maneuver of two
armies that Caesar's
description is difficult to go
because it's going back.
Meanwhile, back at the so--
and so it goes back and forth.
And it takes some real analysis
to figure out what's going on.
Believe me, that
map helps a lot.
Now, here's an illustration
that I think, in fact,
is quite beautiful.
It shows a slinger.
He's not a Roman, probably.
Probably, a Gaul.
Or certainly, somebody
in Italy who is not--
an Italian who's not Roman.
Very possibly, slingers came
from Numidia or from Crete.
So he could be one of these.
And he's about to throw--
he's surrounded with others.
This one's just going
to throw with his hand.
And he's got his weapons
there, his ammunition.
And over here, it goes on
to show somebody firing
a scorpion.
And that's the
ammunition lined up
for a scorpion, which
is a small catapult.
That's a pretty picture.
This next one gives
you verisimilitude
and the historicity.
These are two wire
containers, as you can
scale by the gentleman there.
They're at Uxellodunum,
the last battle
that Caesar fought in Gaul.
And they contain literally
thousands of sling stones
that were gathered from
the battlefield, which
is not a big area.
Believe me, it wasn't as
big as the campus here.
And piled up just to
see how many there were.
And one wasn't enough.
They had to get
another container.
And I don't think
it's been counted,
but there are thousands of them.
And it indicates the scale of
how this ammunition was used,
even in what was a relatively
small battle in a fairly
confined space.
Part of a siege.
So if you see this, you know
that that's not a fairy tale.
There they are.
There are the stones that people
were throwing at each other.
Before I go on with this, I
want to talk about the fact
that the format of
the Landmark series
ran into a tremendous
amount of data about Caesar.
There are five extant,
ancient, contemporary,
or almost contemporary sources--
historians, whose work we have--
and they wrote about Caesar.
And there's just about nobody
else in the ancient world
that we have that
much material on.
Plus you have all
kinds of letters
from Cicero, to his brother,
to Atticus, to various people.
There are letters
from Cicero to Caesar.
And letters from
Caesar back to Cicero.
There's not a lot, but some.
So that, again, they
must be real people.
They say, how is
your daughter doing?
I understand she was sick.
Well, that's personal.
And it makes it
clear that these were
people talking to each other
and not some historic document.
But we learn lots of things
about Caesar from it.
Cicero's letters
often have gossip.
Oh, I heard Caesar was
at Lutetia on the 17th.
He's supposed to have
suffered a bad defeat, which
we know is not true.
But that's what Cicero--
that's the misinformation
that Cicero had at that day.
And those kind of
things really help
us to understand
and see a continuity
of what was happening.
And what it looked like
in Rome, because Cicero
stayed in Rome when all--
or at least at home in
Arpinum during all this time.
This is to show you--
well, I'm not going
to get to this yet.
Let me go back again.
We had so much data, we did not
know how to put it together.
I knew as Kurt came up with more
and more ideas for appendices
that we were running
over what we would have.
But I assumed, frankly,
as the series editor,
that we'd find a way to
reduce the size as we
had done in previous editions.
Another problem is as you're
doing one of these books,
you don't know how many
pages you've accrued.
Your 8-by-11 type
script does not at all
represent how many
pages you have.
So it wasn't until
we finished and we
had it paginated by the genius
lady, Kim Llewellyn, who
makes these pages work
and be attractive even.
Being attractive is
not trivial for a book
that you want the lay readers
to delve into and find
useful and interesting.
So in order to
have it paginated,
she worked hard on it.
And we came out with
1,350 to 1,400 pages.
Now, a trade book--
I don't have one here.
I was sure one would be here.
But a trade book is
about this thick.
About 950 to 1,000 pages
is all it can accommodate.
So I went to the publisher
and I said, can we
do a second volume?
And he said, absolutely not.
And I think he's right.
You're not going to get two
volumes bought, of which one
is only essays about Caesar.
So we had to come up
with another solution.
To make a long story
short, we went to the web.
It's the only place we could go.
It was a brilliant solution,
but the only solution possible.
So some 40 appendices,
now called web essays,
are still an integral
part of the book.
You still have a
footnote there that
says see web essay L for
stuff about Lucius so-and-so.
And you can go to it
with a few finger clicks.
Or you can take
down the appendices
and download them yourself
to your own computer.
Or you can take them down to a
disk or you can print them out.
So they're all very
accessible to you.
And they're even accessible to
people who don't read our book
and don't buy it
because it's on the web
and we're not going to try to
code it and make it difficult.
It's fine if they get it.
Our goal is to-- we're hoping
if somebody does that, they'll
end up buying the book because
they'll want to know where
these things came from.
But basically, what we have
here is almost 30% of the book
is not printed.
It's not in the book because
of the printed medium's
limitations.
We couldn't get in one
volume all of the material.
And I was reluctant
to really cut it hard
because once I read them
all with that intention,
they were extremely good essays.
As a body, they formed
a terrific amount
of supplementary
material for somebody
who's interested in learning
about Caesar in his time.
And Caesar's time was one of
those interesting moments.
A 500-year government is
breaking down, breaking apart.
When we started, we didn't
think there was any relevance
to that, to our modern day.
But right now,
there are people who
suspect that the
American government is
in a situation where
norms are being stretched
and things don't
look like the way
they did 10 or 20 years ago.
And it's conceivable
that, in fact, this
is part of a
process that's going
to end with a major
change in the government.
I don't know, but there
are parallel items,
stretches of the norms in
Caesar and going on today.
So let's now turn to the
maps and the battlefields.
This-- I know you
can't see where it is.
It's in the central,
northwest of--
northeast of Paris.
Paris is about here somewhere.
And up here on the
Sambre River is
where Caesar has a major
battle with the Nervii
tribe, a major Belgian--
Belgae, it's called--
Gallic tribe.
And it's the only
instance I know of where
he's taken by surprise.
He's informed that the Nervii
and their allies are here.
He comes up here
to build a camp.
Everybody pitches in
to build the camp.
When suddenly, out
of the nearby woods
come the Atrebates, the
Viromandui, and the Nervii.
And he writes about it.
Says, they came down the
hill, across the river,
and up the hill so fast, it was
like it all happened at once.
And his Latin was probably
much, much swifter than that.
And in the next part of his
writing, it's an absolute--
maybe one of the best, if
not the best description
of an ancient battle.
Because he describes
what he had to do.
He gives tribute to the
soldiers that if they weren't
by their own unit, they
fell in line in nearby units
because their training was good.
Some of them had no time
to put their helmets on.
They couldn't take-- the shields
are carried in a shield cover.
They couldn't take
the covers off.
And so they are really
under assault suddenly
and without preparation.
And they're surprised.
And they could have
been overwhelmed.
But being Roman soldiers,
they fall into line
and they start the battle.
He goes to the 10th Legion,
which is his favorite,
and starts as he says.
And he gives them a pep talk
and sends them across the river.
The 11th and 8th
Legion deal with--
I'll show you the next slide--
deal with the Viromandui.
But the crisis forms
here on the Roman right,
where the 7th and 12th Legion
are overwhelmed and almost
encircled by the Nervii.
Here's the 9th and 10th
having defeated the Atrebates.
The 11th and 8th have stabilized
and held off the Viromandui.
But the Nervii are
getting around the 7th
and threatening the 12th.
And entering even the
half-built Roman camp.
And normally, if you
enter the enemy's camp,
you win the battle.
Because the enemy
soldiers don't want
to stand by and watch all their
belongings and their slaves
or their women
and their servants
and their private
stuff get taken away.
And they go running off
the line to protect that.
That wouldn't be
the total case here,
partly because Romans
were very disciplined.
And partly because the
camp not being completed,
probably didn't have all of
those accoutrements in it.
But there still
was a chance that--
Caesar says when
he got there, he
saw the men clumping
together, which
is a very bad thing for
the kind of warfare it is.
You have to have space for
people to use their weapons.
He saw some of them wavering and
beginning to head to the rear.
He saw confusion and
so many of the officers
killed that there was
actually a lack in some
of the units of direction.
And so-- he only did
this twice, I think--
he grabs a shield
from a soldier.
And probably with
his red cloak, he's
very-- that's a general's cloak.
He's very visible.
He runs up to the
front line and he
calls on the centurions, who
are the sergeants of the era.
And he calls them by name to
come and to give direction
and put the lines together.
And I figured out that there
were eight legions in his army,
and there are 60 centurions
in each army-- each legion.
And so we can assume he had
480 to 500 centurions, which
he knew by name.
And I think I read somewhere
that he had a fabulous memory
for things like that.
And here's a case where he
used that to good effect
as a general.
In the end, he put the
12th Legion behind the 7th.
He moved it, flitted
over, faced it around
so it was facing this way, which
was stopping the encirclement.
And at least protected
the 7th from the rear.
Labienus was on the hill here,
the general of the 10th Legion.
And he saw what was happening,
and he sent the 10th Legion
all across the battlefield
here, which went
to the flank of the Nervii.
And these two, which were
green recruit legions,
had been used only to
accompany the baggage.
Their appearance
on the scene was
enough to give the Nervii
pause because they were there
in the flank and the rear.
So basically, the
battle was stabilized.
The Romans when they
got a stabilized battle,
they could fight the Germans
and the Gauls to a finish
because they had a better
means of replacement,
and better weapons,
and better tactics.
And so it ended up
with just butchery.
Caesar does say
that the Germans--
that the Nervii
just kept coming.
They would climb now the
rampart that the dead bodies
of their compatriots
formed and be
fighting from above with
them until they were killed.
And then, new ones stepped
up, until the day was over
and most of them were dead.
He ends that their reputation
for valor was justified.
OK.
That's one battle which shows
him operating in an emergency.
You've got to remember,
this is his second year
of his campaigning.
He doesn't have the seven
years where these guys--
where he's a successful general.
He's made them all rich.
They're completely
devoted to him.
He had to really show what
he could do here in order
to save this situation.
His main opponent was a
former military genius,
a Roman one named Pompey.
And here the two of them are.
And as I mentioned before,
at Dyrrachium Pompey defeated
Caesar rather handily.
Caesar made an error here.
Two of them.
He left open a part
of a fortification,
which he should have closed.
He didn't blame himself, but
he should have blamed himself.
And then he saw an opportunity
for a counterattack,
which was risky.
And he sent his men into it and
they got lost in the terrain.
They had not really
reconnoitered it well enough.
And they broke down some walls--
holes in walls, so
they could get through.
And when Pompey counterattacked
and they needed to retreat,
those holes in the walls
became choke points.
And so many of their
casualties were men
being trampled as others fled.
The cavalry also tried
to get back through them.
It was a disaster.
And right away, Caesar
had to break the siege.
Here's that map again.
Caesar went down south,
avoided Pompey's pursuit.
And then they went on
their ways to Pharsalus.
And I mentioned at Pharsalus,
for a few days there--
we don't know how many days--
Caesar would offer battle and
Pompey wouldn't accept it.
Pompey knew that
his troops would not
stand up to Caesar's, even
though Pompey had twice as
many.
He had Roman recruits
and Greek recruits.
And Caesar had real veterans
who had been through eight,
nine years of heavy warfare.
So Pompey didn't want to fight.
But his men misjudged the nature
of their victory at Dyrrachium.
They thought they
had won it by--
how much?
Zero.
OK, quickly.
They thought they had
won it with great skill
and Caesar was finished.
And so they wanted to battle.
Pompey accepted it
with a special plan
that he was going to use his
cavalry, which he had 7,000
to about a 1,000 of Caesar's
to overwhelm Caesar's cavalry
and fight--
attack the Caesar in the rear.
Caesar's counter-plan was
to bring a fourth line up
by calling on cohorts
from his third line.
And that worked just right.
They attacked Pompey's
cavalry from the flank.
They threw them out.
And then they-- that
is, the fourth line--
walked past Pompey's flank
and attacked the rear.
Caesar sent his third line
in and Pompey's troops broke.
And it was a major victory.
Here I just say he's
a major tactician.
He foresaw what was
going to happen.
He organized his troops,
a successful counter.
His role was just to set it in
motion and watch what happened,
at least as he describes it.
And it happened pretty
much according to his plan.
But I want to show
you one last picture.
It's a map.
I don't know if you can see it.
Down here is Egypt.
Up there is northeastern Turkey.
Here's Thessaly,
where Pharsalus was.
Here's the Adriatic.
Here's Italy.
Here's Africa, Spain, and Gaul.
Caesar fought
battles everywhere.
In these 14 years, he was
a general whose chessboard
was the entire Mediterranean.
And I leave you with that
thought and this image.
And I turn it over to my
colleague, Professor Raaflaub.
[APPLAUSE]
KURT A. RAAFLAUB:
Good afternoon.
I'm Kurt Raaflaub.
I'm the editor of this work.
But I want to start--
I will build on
Bob's presentation.
But before I start,
I want to just say
that this volume is really the
result of teamwork, of very
rare and high-quality teamwork.
Bob has assembled a group
of very devoted specialists.
And he, himself, has shown
throughout the process
an incredible commitment
to producing this volume.
I spent lots of time on it, but
he's spent nearly as much time
on it.
Spending hours and hours
talking with the cartographers,
designing the maps himself.
I corrected them, sent them
back, he sent them back.
And when we both were
convinced this is what it is,
he went to his freelance
cartographers, who then
produced these beautiful maps.
And the negotiations
behind this, I just
know that they happened.
But then, illustrations
and everything else.
And these specialists
are high-quality people
who are really committed
to producing these volumes.
So I could not have done
anything like this on my own.
And I'm very grateful
to Bob and his team,
that they showed this commitment
and produced this, which
I think a very useful volume.
I thought I would start by
showing you the difficulties.
Bob talked about the
difficulties that Caesar posed.
He wrote his, what
was called Comentarii,
which is a report on these
Gallic wars, on his own wars.
But he had literary ambitions.
And he didn't want to
write a general's report.
Generals give dates and
distances and routes,
and so on.
Historians don't.
And Caesar knew
Thucydides very well,
so he knew that historians
don't go into these details.
They show the big outlines,
and the dramatic episodes,
and so on.
And that's what
Caesar wanted to do.
So for us modern scholars
to reconstruct the way
that Caesar fought
this war in Gaul based
on his very limited
information that he
gives in this respect was
sometimes quite difficult.
And I want to illustrate this
for you with two episodes,
at both the landings in
Britain in 55 and in 54.
In 55, he tells us that
he landed three days
before a full moon night.
During that night,
the storm combined
with the springtide heavily
damaged the anchored fleet.
Now, we know because scientists
have calculated this.
And we know that the
times of the dates
of full moons and new moons and
equinoxes back to Caesar's time
and farther back.
So we know that full moon
nights in the late summer of 55
were three--
July 31, August 30,
and September 28.
And Caesar tells us he
returned to the mainland
before the equinox,
the fall equinox, which
was on September 26.
So the date for the full moon
of September 28 is too late.
If we add up, as we
did, all the time Caesar
must have consumed for
his trips before he
came to the start-off point
for the expedition to Britain,
you don't see the ocean lines.
This is very unfortunate,
but that's what it is.
Here, Portus Itius,
moderne Boulogne-sur-Mer.
And here is Caesar's
departure for Britain.
Before he arrived there,
he did various things,
crossing Gaul from
west to east and back.
And so just barely
enough time for him
to reach the departure
point and to get to Britain.
So we can say that the July 31
date is absolutely too early.
It cannot have been that.
That leaves one date, and
that is the August 27,
the full moon, and the
springtide of that date, which
helps us date precisely
when Caesar actually
landed in Britain.
Now, the second case
of the landing in 54
is more interesting
and more complicated.
Caesar writes he sets
sail around sunset,
is carried by a southwest wind.
Around midnight, the wind stops.
The current drives
him far to the east.
You see that on the map
with the arrow there.
And then around dawn,
he sees far to the left
the coast of Britain.
And then the current changes
and carries him back.
And when he uses the rows and
he finds the landing's beach
and is able to land.
The second night
after his landing,
there is another huge storm.
And that again damages
his fleet very heavily.
The whole army works for 10 days
to repair as many of the ships
as possible.
So that's what Caesar
tells us himself.
Scholars naturally connect
this storm with a full moon
as it was in the previous year.
I don't think this could
be because Caesar knew
that full moons are dangerous.
And so he would have
taken special precautions.
But anyway, that's what
scholars tend to do.
Now, Bob mentioned
the correspondence
between the subcommander,
the deputy commander,
Quintus Cicero, who
was a subcommander
in Caesar's army at the time.
And his brother, the famous
orator, Marcus Tullius Cicero--
Tully in early
American language--
in Rome.
And from this
correspondence, we can
derive with absolute certainty
that August 2 or 3 in the Roman
calendar system was the latest
possible date for Caesar's
landing in Britain.
Hence, the full moon of
August 14 is too late.
But there was a new moon on
the night of July 30, 31.
And we know that new moon and
full moon are equally liable--
likely to produce
springtides, so on.
Now, the pattern
that Caesar describes
for what happened to him
when he crossed over,
studying these patterns over a
long period of time have found
applies only to the days
shortly before a full moon
or a new moon.
So here is what they sent us.
We wrote to the National
Oceanographic Institute
in Liverpool and found
an interested person who
sent us these illustrations.
And you see that exactly
what Caesar describes
happens in these schemes--
current to the northeast,
current to the southwest
after 5:00 AM.
And this is Caesar.
So we know it had to be
just before a full moon
or a new moon.
And so that helps us
because Caesar says two
days before this, he landed.
It must have been July 29.
And again, if we add all
the activities of Caesar
before then, it couldn't
have been an earlier date.
So that helps us.
And this is actually
completely new with certainty
to date the second landing
on the 29th of July.
Right?
Yes.
Now, Caesar is a
fascinating personality.
He came from a family
that was very old,
went back to the beginnings of
Rome, or even to the goddess
Venus as ancestress
of the family.
It had lost much of
its luster over time.
There were no famous
immediate ancestors of Caesar,
but he belonged to the
highest aristocracy.
And he took that very seriously.
His aunt was the wife of the
famous war hero Gaius Marius.
And Gaius Marius was a
populist politician in Rome.
In the 80s, there were
civil wars between--
you may have heard the
name of Sulla and Marius.
And Sulla was a
very conservative
right-wing politician
who, when he was in power,
ordered Caesar to
divorce his wife,
who was the daughter
of the heir of Marius.
And Caesar refused,
putting himself
into a very dangerous situation.
He survived it, but this
prompted him to become really
a convinced populist
against this entrenched
aristocracy in the Senate
that were the heirs of Sulla.
And he was also a
very ambitious man.
He was a gambler.
He loved to play at high stakes.
And he was always
in debt and had
to be bailed out, even before
he could leave for an earlier
provincial command by the
richest man in Rome, Marcus
Crassus.
And all that combined to
make a lot of enemies.
The entrenched aristocracy
didn't like Caesar.
And so they put all the
obstacles in his way
that they could.
And he knew that he would
not secure an election
to the consulship,
the highest office,
unless he had powerful allies.
And so he formed
this Triple Alliance
with Pompey, mentioned
before, and Crassus,
who both had their reasons to
be at odds with the Senate.
And they secured
Caesar's consulship.
He did favors to them
and they did the favor
that they secured for him a
big provincial command in Gaul.
Because in the
meantime, earlier Pompey
had done great
conquests in the east,
fighting the famous
Mithridates and had
added provinces and territories
to the Roman Empire.
He had raised the bar.
If one wanted to be
the greatest Roman,
one had to be
better than Pompey.
And Caesar was
extremely ambitious.
And he, therefore,
secured these commands,
and then hoped that there
would be an opportunity
to create a war and start a war.
And the Helvetians in the first
year gave him the opportunity.
And out of this developed
this entire war, which he then
described not only in his
reports to the Senate,
but in these elaborated
commentaries,
reports that we now
have and can read.
And they gave us
so many insights
into how a leading
Roman of the time
perceived his role, perceived
the role of the army, the role
of a general, as Bob described
it, the role of a leader.
And I just put in a
few possible focuses
one could talk about
in this context--
the perfect Roman,
the perfect general,
which is very important
for Roman cultural history.
He was an extremely
talented author as we
shall see in a moment, I hope.
And at the end,
I would just like
to briefly talk about
what is the dark side
of this whole story.
Namely, the brutality
of imperial conquest,
the masses of losses
that it caused in Gaul.
And balance this by looking at
Caesar as the clement victor
because Caesar was very
innovative in this way as well.
So I will see how far
I get with all this.
This is Caesar, the
organizer and improviser.
Imagine for a
moment that this is
a war that is fought
in an unknown country.
Caesar didn't know
where he was going.
He didn't have maps.
There were no maps.
And there was no developed
good road network.
So Caesar had to balance this
shortcoming by building up
an extensive network of
intelligence, questioning
all kinds of people
about where he was going
and where the goals were
that he was aiming at.
A highly-developed
system of logistics,
bringing the supplies
for an increasing number
of legions, tens of
thousands of soldiers
who needed to be fed and
supported with boots, and so
on.
Reliance on the group
of favored allies
who helped him with
difficulties that he
might have in these
supplies, storage,
increasing number
of hostages that
were given by the
defeated peoples that
needed to be somewhere.
Caesar couldn't take them
all along on his campaigns,
so he relied on
some of these allies
to take care of these hostages.
He needed to be extremely
versatile in mastering
the challenges of naval and
siege warfare, engineering.
I'll show you an
example in a moment.
And in short, his
inventiveness was called for.
Circumspection, his ability
to think outside the box,
of finding solutions
that were unusual,
understanding the conditions
under which his army fought,
both from the enemy side
and from his own side.
Caesar, for example, never
led his army into a fight
before he knew that
they were rested enough
and they had eaten before
they went into battle.
One of his subcommanders
at some point
ignored these elementary
rules and promptly suffered
very bad defeat.
Using even deception
systematically and frequently,
but always based on a
psychological assessment
of the enemy.
How far he could go,
how he could trick them.
And he did that as
much as he could.
But let me show you here another
aspect we tend to forget.
Namely, that Caesar's
army was on its own.
And he needed the specialists
in his army, the engineers,
who would train the
soldiers to do the works.
So they knew what
they had to do.
The engineers provided
the blueprint.
OK, this is going to be a
bridge with 20-feet-long timber
crossing the Rhine.
In 54, a bridge built
across the Rhine 400 meters
wide and 12 feet deep
on average in 10 days
once the lumber
started to come in.
A major achievement-- and Caesar
tells about it very proudly
because he was aware that he
had accomplished something
very extraordinary here.
Or the ability to improvise
and surprise the enemy.
His famous speed, the speed is
one of the most frequent words
that he uses, his celeritas.
And there's an example
I give you here.
His effort to get
back to his army
when the big rebellion of
52 led by Vercingetorix
had broken out.
He came to the province
here in the south.
Here's the province.
And he had to get up here
where his legions were
in winter quarters.
And this was all enemy-infested,
rebellious territory.
And the enemy was convinced
that Caesar couldn't
reach his legions
because they were
in control of the territory.
So what Caesar
did was he started
a diversionary attack
across a mountain
range-- the Cevennes
mountains-- in winter.
There were 10-feet-high
walls of snow and ice.
And his army cut through
and made a path for him.
He led parts of his army into
the territory of the Arverni,
which was the tribe, the
nation of his enemy leader--
general.
And he started to
devastate the country.
The Vercingetorix was
operating up here.
He was called back by his people
to defend his own country.
Caesar then himself went
back to the Rhone valley,
joined a cavalry escort
that was well-rested here.
And then in four
days and nights,
dashed up to meet his
legions and reunite his army
before the enemy even
knew what was going on.
That is an example of his
inventiveness, of his speed,
of his ability to surprise
and reach success here.
Another aspect I want to bring
out, which is his leadership.
It's not the same
as his generalship.
His ability to bond
with his soldiers,
to create an army that
was in deep loyalty
tied to him and of which he
could expect total effort,
but he had to create this bond.
And he was extremely
good in doing that.
During a very difficult
siege at Avaricum, he--
in winter, where the food
supply was interrupted
because the enemy was using
a scorched earth strategy,
Caesar offered to his
soldiers to give up.
If this is too hard
for you, let's go.
We can try something else.
And the soldiers said, no.
We never give up.
We never gave up.
We never betray you.
So let's finish this up.
But showing this
compassion, even
sleeping out with his soldiers
on guard during the night,
so that they knew he was
part of the enterprise
and he was not somewhere
in a warm bunker,
but he was right there where
the action was taking place.
This is a hypothetical
reconstruction
on the left of this siege.
The siege works at Avaricum,
an 80-foot-high siege ramp,
a tower, and covered galleries.
And on the right,
I just showed you
the Masada where the Roman siege
ramp is still visible here.
So that is also a very steep
ramp on which a tower was then
moved up so it could
shoot across the wall
and defeat the enemies.
You see the Roman
camps here and here.
And there's one
down here as well.
So this gives us an idea of
what was going on in Avaricum.
Just very briefly other
aspects of leadership.
Bob mentioned this.
Exposing himself to
danger, taking the shield,
rushing to the front,
encouraging his soldiers.
And through his
presence, giving courage
to the soldiers who always in
the presence of the general
tried to excel and show, and
of course, hope for rewards.
But this was very crucial
to stabilize the situation
and actually, as I
say, steal victory out
of the jaws of defeat.
Then, other aspects.
Caring for his soldiers' lives.
Caesar often-- several
times at least--
forfeited a certain
victory or an easy victory
because he wanted
to avoid the losses
this would cause
to his soldiers.
He was very generous in
rewarding outstanding
performances of
soldiers and officers.
He shared the hardships.
He was able to build up a
very deep sense of loyalty.
He says at some point
during the civil war,
when two officers,
Gallic officers,
deserted to the enemy, that
this was the first time
ever that this has happened.
While constantly
there was a flow of
deserters from the enemy to
his camp in all his campaigns.
And he gives us an example of
an officer who was captured
and who was offered his
life and monetary rewards
if he fought against
Caesar with his enemies.
And he not only
refused to do that,
but he offered the
commander of the enemy
an opportunity to see
what the enemy was
he was fighting against.
He said, give me
10 men of my own
and I will fight against the
whole company of your troops
and you will see against
whom you are fighting.
And then, of course, he
was immediately executed.
But the story is told
by one of his officers
as an example of this loyalty.
And then, my favorite episode.
Caesar was impatient.
He departed for the
African war in 46,
before his army had
completely assembled.
And then there was a storm
and his whole flotilla
was dispersed.
He arrived with just a
couple of thousand soldiers
and a few hundred cavalry.
And for two days, the
others didn't show up.
So he put soldiers on
ships in the harbor
and waited during the night.
He didn't tell his soldiers
what he had in mind
because he knew that
there was communication
across the fronts.
And he didn't want his
plan to be betrayed.
And then the soldiers
were very despondent.
They knew they were a few,
they were inexperienced,
they were new
recruits, and so on.
And this is what
this author writes.
This is, again, the officer
that writes this, not Caesar
himself.
"These soldiers
sitting on the ships
could not find any
kind of comfort
in their present circumstance.
All they could do was look
to their general's face,
which was full of heartiness
and unbelievably good spirits.
His courage was like a standard.
He carried in front.
He carried straight up
high right in front of him.
This calmed down the men.
And trusting his
expertise and planning,
they all hoped that everything
would turn out well for them."
Imagine-- this is the way
that they saw their general,
these soldiers.
That's part of the secret
of Caesar's success.
I'm not going to
talk about this.
Caesar was also a very talented
author, an intellectual
of the highest rank.
He could hold his own in
discussions with philosophers.
And he was one of
the great orators.
He only gave speeches at
the beginning of his career,
but these made
such an impression
that Cicero said he was ranking
among the highest, the best
orators that Rome ever had.
He was an expert in style.
He wrote his historical
works, his commentaries,
with the intention that
anybody could read them--
uneducated/educated persons.
And so he created a very simple,
straightforward, clear style
that conveyed clearly
what he wanted to convey.
And he wrote a work on good
style, good Latin style.
And he dictated
this work while he
was traveling on
horseback across the Alps
to rejoin his army.
Very unusual.
And then, of course, he also
wrote these commentaries.
And they were
praised very highly.
I only gave you the
second quote by Hirtius,
who wrote the eighth
book of the Gallic war.
"The universal judgment
is that other writers,
despite their
painstaking efforts
have produced
nothing that is not
outdone by the refined elegance
of Caesar's commentaries.
They have been received
with unanimous approval.
Yet we may feel greater
admiration than all others,
for they know how well
and faultlessly he wrote,
while we also know with
what ease and speed
he completed the work."
So this is Caesar,
the intellectual.
Let me just for the
end, turn briefly
to what I call "the dark side."
Of course, this conquest of
Gaul caused enormous losses.
Here you have the tally,
the casualty count.
1 million Celts dead,
1 million enslaved.
This is what ancient
authors tell us.
Out of the population
of 8 to 12 million--
reasonable estimates--
one fourth to one sixth
of the total population
died in these conquests.
In his triumph, in his great
victory celebration of 46,
Caesar listed the total
number of casualties, enemy
casualties, in his battles.
Not just in Gaul, but
all over the place.
1,192,000.
These are staggering figures.
And if you read
Caesar's story, when
enemy swore an oath
of capitulation,
and then broke the oath
and started to fight again,
punishment was
absolutely brutal.
Either execution or enslavement.
This is from
Trajan's Column where
you see a scene like that.
The Gallic War is beautifully
illustrated by this spiral
column in Rome, which is, of
course, almost 200 years later.
But the army didn't change
much in the meantime.
And it, therefore,
gives us a good idea.
And I just give you
two examples of where
the label of genocide that has
sometimes been used for Caesar
actually would apply.
One is a campaign in 55,
where Caesar massacred
two German nations that
had crossed over into Gaul,
and that he distrusted deeply.
He wanted them out.
And since they didn't
react quickly enough,
he just massacred
children, women, everybody.
And he gives the
number as 430,000.
Probably vastly exaggerated.
But still, this was a
campaign of elimination.
And that is very bad.
And then, there was
one enemy leader,
a leader of a Gallic nation.
His name was Ambiorix.
He had been a
friend of Caesar's.
He had served in his army.
And then he attacked
one of his winter camps
and tricked the
Caesar subcommanders
into leaving the camp, and
then ambushed and annihilated
one and a half legions.
And Caesar pursued this man
with deep hatred after that.
And not only the man
himself, but his nation.
And it was his goal to
eradicate this nation,
so that if Ambiorix ever
came back to his nation,
he would not find anybody
whom he could rely on.
That was a campaign of
revenge and eradication.
That is, again, quite radical.
On the other hand, there
is a balance to this.
Caesar is to my
knowledge, the first,
perhaps the only
ancient general,
who made clemency
his watch word, who
declared it to be his goal
and his default action
and did it whenever he could.
If an enemy capitulated
before fighting broke out,
they could expect
to suffer no harm.
And I give you two quotes
from the Gallic War.
He said to a tribe
named the Atuatuci,
"He would spare their nation--
more because it was his habit
than because they deserved it--
if they surrendered
before the battering ram
touched their wall."
And in the last year of the
war, in Uxellodunum, which was
mentioned by Bob, he punished--
he had to set an
example because he
wanted this constant
rebelling to stop.
He knew his command
was coming to an end.
He wanted to leave a
pacified and quiet country.
And so he punished
when they capitulated.
He punished the defenders,
the men who had been fighting,
by cutting off their hands.
Letting them live, but
cutting off their hands.
And he writes, "Caesar was aware
that his merciful disposition
was known to everyone,
and he did not
need to be afraid that if he
acted more harshly than usual,
it would be ascribed to
his cruel character."
But then in the civil war,
both Pompey and Caesar
were expected to
behave like Sulla had,
with relentless persecution
of their opponents.
And then after
his first victory,
even a large number of elite
Romans fell into his hands.
He let them sensationally
go unharmed.
And that brought a big
turn in public opinion.
And in a letter that was
disseminated throughout Italy--
and Cicero has a copy.
And in his letters, we
can read that copy--
he made this
programmatic statement
to two of his supporters.
"I'm glad that you approve of
what happened at Corfinium"--
that's the place.
"I had already
decided on a policy
to demonstrate as much
leniency as possible.
Let's try whether in
this way we can regain
the goodwill of all people
and achieve lasting victory,
because others have not
been able by cruelty
to escape hatred and
to hold onto victory
for any length of time--
except only for Sulla whom
I not going to imitate.
Let this be our new
way of conquering--
to protect ourselves by
mercy and generosity."
I find this one of the
very impressive statements
in history.
In an earlier episode
in the civil war,
Caesar had trapped an enemy
army, immobilized them.
And his army, his own army,
was sensing an easy victory
and demanding the
command to attack.
And Caesar refused.
And he writes, "He
had come to hope
that he could finish this
business without a battle
and without exposing any
of his men to injury.
Why, he thought, should he
risk losing some of his men,
even in a successful battle?
Why should he
accept that soldiers
who had served him with supreme
loyalty would be wounded?
He was also moved by pity
for his fellow citizens
on the other side who, he
knew, would have to be killed.
He preferred to achieve
his objective while they
were safe and unharmed."
And so he forced
them to capitulate
by starving them out.
So the idea, the
propagation of clemency
as a general's and
ruler's cardinal virtue
is Caesar's merit.
And Augustus was the first,
who after the victory
in the civil wars, was
given by the Senate
a shield, a golden shield,
inscribed by the four--
what became the four
cardinal virtues--
virtue, clemency,
justice, and piety.
And we have the inscription.
We have copies of it.
It's illustrated on coins.
So Augustus was the first
who actually expressed
these cardinal virtues, but they
go back to Caesar's initiative.
And I think that is worth
recording and mentioning
because that also helps to
balance that dark picture which
I drew earlier.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]